where's father deserve the piece cast
aside selfish ambition actually for the
good of the realm where his father's
done settled I surrendered my power to
you
she has returned
seek out the fire and return home if
people need you
you took everything from me we gave up
everything to pursue your twisted dream
your way is cold and brutal still is
[Music]
bring it back
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is a brand new Avengers infinity saga
deleted scene that Marvel released
obviously this is for Thor Loki Odin in
hella there's a bunch of different stuff
going on in here so we'll break it all
down some really cool Easter eggs and
deleted storylines that didn't make it
into the movies primarily Thor getting
the odinforce if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the Marvel videos we're doing that
giveaway for the Infinity Saga box set
that's where this scene actually came
from all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave all your theories
about Thor 4 on the video so we'll just
break this down top 5 style I cut the
scene way down it's like a four and a
half minute scene but I couldn't post
the entire thing so this is just cut up
into some of the more important bits but
it's meant to be an alternate version of
what happens after they leave the
sanctum sanctorum like after Loki falls
out of that portal it tries to go after
Doctor Strange instead of porting them
to Norway he ported them to the street
they walked down the street and right
around the corner in an alleyway is
where they find Odin they spent a lot of
time finishing this a lot of the
dialogue is different it goes down in a
very different way in almost all the
special effects or at least somewhat
finished so I'll explain after this why
they wound up deleting this and going
with the alternate version of the scene
as you probably noticed there are Easter
eggs and the graffiti and the posters
all over this alleyway so I'll point
them out as we go through a top 5 but
starting with number 5 Odin who's lost
some of his memory but apparently starts
to get it back when Thor and Loki show
up starts rambling about Ragnarok
repeating the line seek out the fire
obviously that's not something that he
said in the final version of the scene
that we saw in theaters then really big
deal he names Thor the new all-father
that's what's happening here passing all
of his power to him as he says that
obviously didn't include any special
effects for this because they deleted
the scene that's what some of the
special effects look like ps2 graphics
that's what it looks like before they
polish it like if they wind up deleting
a scene they're not gonna spend hours
and hours and hours working on it to
make it look good if they know it's not
gonna be in the movie the version of
thor ragnarok that we got in theaters
changed Thor's powers a little bit from
the comics and a little bit of the Thor
mythology from Marvel Comics I think
mostly in service of streamlining the
narrative of Thor recognizing his own
self-worth his hammer Mjolnir wasn't his
only source of power all kinds of
metaphors and jokes you could lay on him
with that
hammer but the odinforce is a huge huge
deal in the comics it's the source of
Odin's power as the name implies but it
makes him nearly invincible in one of
the most powerful characters in Marvel
Comics his only real weakness is that in
order to sustain himself he has to go
into a deep sleep once every millennia
or so called the odinsleep to restore
his lifeforce during which he's
completely helpless number four they
kind of did a version of that during the
first Thor movie but by the time they
got to Thor Ragnarok they had
sidestepped a lot of that part of the
comics but it sounds like based on this
part of the deleted scene they had
intended on bringing that back I know a
lot of people were disappointed in the
way they portray Thor in some of the
movies but once that would have happened
when Thor claims the odinforce as his
own and becomes the new all-father
the power within him is called the Thor
force it changes a little bit if you've
ever watched my hero academia funny
anime reference it's a little bit like
all my passing his quirk one for all to
midoriya and within him the power
develops becomes even greater and he
develops new abilities with it that his
predecessor all might didn't think to
try eventually someday he'll pass the
power on to his successor who will grow
that power even more and so on and so
forth it's sort of the life force power
that gets passed on from father to son
in fact the odinforce itself was created
during an adventure with Serdar who
obviously is a big part of the story
they talk about it a little bit at the
beginning of Thor Ragnarok the origin of
the odinforce is actually the combined
life force of Odin's two brothers who
were killed by a Serdar
remember at the beginning of Thor
Ragnarok where Serdar is going on and on
about his history with Odin how he's
been trapped here been forced to live
this meagre existence when Odin did all
that he did it with the help of his two
brothers but they were killed in battle
and Odin absorbed their life force it
Kuroda gave him this massive powerup
that they then called the odinforce so
here in this moment when Odin is passing
his power as he says to Thor he's
basically passing his life force energy
to him which is why it's so easy for
Heller to kill him because even though
he's really old he's still one of the
most powerful people in the Marvel
Universe they kind of power down the
Asgardians a little bit in the Marvel
movies the way they portray them but
really when you think about it they are
some of the most powerful characters in
the galaxy you also notice in the
background - there's a lot of thunder
love posters next to the journey
- mystery posters obviously journey into
mystery is where Thor debuted in the
comics before they did a Thor solo title
but the Thunder loved posters obviously
foreshadow the eventual title that he
would pick for Thor for love and thunder
now he only wrote that movie in the last
year and thor ragnarok was made a couple
years ago so it sounds like he was
already kind of thinking about a fourth
Thor movie at that time number three
there's also another big scene here that
Odin has with Loki I didn't include it
in the clip at the beginning of this but
it's a moment he has with Loki telling
him that all of his lawless nature the
storms within him he inherited from Odin
acknowledging him as his son in a way
that he had been wanting so badly for so
long if you've ever listened to Tom
Hiddleston talk about Loki conventions
he's talked a lot about the pain and
loneliness that Loki carries around with
him and that being the driving force
that causes him to act out and cause all
this mischief in the way that he does
Tom Hiddleston says he has this
desperate need to belong somewhere and
how a lot of his early rebellious nough
sand early villainy through the avengers
movie was mostly because that had just
reached a boiling point and he was
mostly just lashing out because he had
wanted odin to fully accept him as his
son which he obviously did just before
dying it's just that this version of the
scene has way way more dialogue which i
think is pretty cool but I also kind of
liked the version they did in the
theatrical cut number two the bigger
Easter eggs and all the Serdar storyline
stuff so Odin when he's talking about
seek the fire he gives Thor this vision
and he sees Ragnarok in the future like
Odin is causing Thor to see into the
future there's all kinds of crazy powers
that they've never really explained in
the Thor movies you have to remember
that Odin can also weave magic the same
way that Loki in freaka can it's just
that he's not quite as good as Frigga
and Frigga is the one that taught loki
which is why loki is able to ever once
in a while trick odin using his magic
but when Oda is rambling about seeking
the fire it's him trying to tell Thor
and Loki that Serdar was the only one
who could defeat hella eventually
setting up the ending scene twist where
Loki throws his skull into the eternal
flame thus fulfilling sergers prophecy
of Ragnarok that they had him speaking
in that funny scene at the beginning of
the movie with Thor interrupting him
even though the Surtur storyline during
the movie is hand in hand with a
Ragnarok story those were actually two
different Thor comic book stories the
surger stuff was inspired by a story
called the Serdar
which is just a trilogy of comics of him
trying to steal the eternal flame to
give him near unlimited power the
Ragnarok destruction of asgaard stuff
was borrowed from Jack Kirby's Ragnarok
which was one of his last stories that
he wrote at Marvel before going to DC to
start doing the fourth world New Gods
stuff in fact the whole idea that Jack
Kirby had one of the reasons why he left
Marvel for DC is because it was a story
he wanted to do with the Thor comics he
wanted to do a version of fourth world
with the Thor characters as part of his
Ragnarok storyline in that original idea
he was basically killing off all these
Thor characters and he was gonna bring
them back because of the cycle of
Ragnarok but was gonna bring them back
in a very fourth world Jack Kirby
looking way Marvel obviously took a hard
pass on that so when he went to DC he
did it as the fourth world New Gods
storyline and obviously slightly
different versions of the characters but
that was kind of what the Thor
characters were going to turn into in
his mind when Marvel told him he wasn't
allowed to do that the number one WTF
fella has a very different final scene
with Odin where she personally kills him
before destroying Thor's hammer they
have a conversation talking about their
history Hellas thymus leader of his
armies when they were conquering the
nine realms why they stopped at 9:00
instead of conquering the rest of the
galaxy in a whi Odin trapped her in an
alternate dimension like I said way more
dialogue from Odin in all these scenes
him explaining a lot of the backstory
and mythology that they used later in
Thor Ragnarok in slightly different ways
they gave some of that dialogue to other
characters and obviously in the
theatrical cut were Odin dies hella is
nowhere to be found she doesn't show up
till after he's gone but if he spotted
any other big easter eggs during this
deleted scene that I didn't mention in
the video just write them below in the
comments the big thing that actually
just happened is they were filming
scenes for venom two in downtown Los
Angeles a really big call-out to Tom
Hollands spider-man was spotted on set
the same way it was in the Morbius
trailer so we'll do a venom two
spider-man Easter Egg video next as long
as you have alerts enabled for my
channel you'll see that video when I
post it but just another confirmation
that there's gonna be a lot of
spider-man stuff happening in the venom
two in Morbius movies
everyone click here to watch my Morbius
trailer breakdown and click here for my
Wanda vision trailer and all those other
Marvel phase 4 trailers thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
is the way